- We've made tap handles for
Budweiser, Goose Island, Miller Lite.
You know, I think this is a first
with an actual snow
globe on the tap handle.
Yee-Haw Pale Ale.
I like this one because it's just a big,
awesome-looking tap handle.
Stiegl, Prescott, and Central
Waters, to name a few.
I'm Mark Steinhardt, General
Manager of AJS Tap Handles.
I definitely would try that beer.
So, a guy walks into a bar,
and the first thing he does, if it's me,
I look what's on tap.
Certainly, the unique tap
handles pique your interest
and might push you to try that beer.
I like this tap handle,
because I'm a road biker.
We're located in Random Lake, Wisconsin,
which is about 45 minutes
north of Milwaukee.
Even though Wisconsin is a rural state,
we produce tap handles
for the mega-breweries
on down to the smallest microbrew.
We believe we're the
largest domestic producer
of tap handles here in the U.S.
We ship out approximately
a half a million tap handles each year.
We can produce the tap
handle from start to finish.
This is a very detailed tap handle,
and I would guess takes about an hour
to hand paint all the detail on it.
Companies do try to have
the most eye-catching,
most unique tap handle in the bar.
And it is a cross between
art and manufacturing.
We always say our tap handle
will sell your first beer,
and your beer will sell the rest.